the rotation number one of the majors in
earned run average aaron sivali gets the
start today his command is impeccable
and he'll begin with whit merrifield who
is playing in his
292nd consecutive game
whit hits it up the right field line
that's a fair ball naquin plays it off
the side wall whit is digging for two
and the throw is a little bit off line
and the royals begin the game with a
runner at second base and for brady
singer this is his second start against
the indians his first is one he'll never
forget his big league debut on this
mound back on july the 25th
and a fastball at the knees is in for a
strike fernandez started the game off
for them last night
and a fastball surprised lendore he took
a very late swing and he strikes out
alex gordon leads off second inning the
one-two is strike three goal nice
comeback heater
first k for savali went away
back-to-back case for savali looked like
he just went powder river right there up
the ladder with a good fastball
boy i'll tell you what savali
you can't pitch any better than he just
did to those three batters strikes out
the side here in the second inning
ugly swing and
brady singer has his third strikeout
oh look at that location he's hard to
strike got that guy way to go
the one-two
smashed up the alley delino will cut it
off
and the only man who's reached base
against aaron sivali
not surprisingly is whitmerfield he's
two for two yeah he's getting hot at
just the the right time you got to get
him out of cleveland now the royals have
two speed guys on and if dozier could
grab one the royals could take the early
lead
and there's a line drive to right field
that's going to be down here's whit
around third
and the throw to the plate is late and
now it gets past hedges monday stays at
second base and the royals take a
one-nothing lead on hunter dozier's
two-out rbi franco he grounded out to
third in the first inning and now a line
drive is into left field and that'll get
two home as the ball gets by naylor
franco will hold and the royals with two
outs and nobody on have scored three
franco he's been knocking some runs in
lately on soft stuff that's floating
down over the middle that's a big curve
way off the plate
oh
man
that's just filthy hard boring eater
you got to go
fastball surprised him
and now he gets him with a slider so
that's six for singer two against
lendore
there's a swing and a miss at a fastball
make it seven strikeouts for the rookie
brady singer
to left center field and slicing over to
alex that looked like a fly ball for the
center fielder but it ended up in alex's
glove and brady singer has no hit the
indians through five
that pit strike three called fastball
and reynolds has
taken another fastball and has struck
out three times tonight that will take
us to edward olivares
look at that swing edward olivares
wow
holy varus
not only is he hit in seven straight for
the royals but that's his
second hit tonight five multi-hit games
there's a good looking swing wow and
naquin is going to have to hustle to cut
it off but cam is going to stop it first
with a lead off single so he's two for
three there's the pitch to front goal
franco
launches it into deep left center field
and that is gone
and the royals
have scored seven runs tonight all
have come with two outs
and franco has driven in five that is a
royals career game for franco fantastic
job of recognizing the pitch
and depositing edge number nine
he struck out lindor twice swinging and
there's a line drive and caught by
reynolds
the only fielder on the left side
and matt reynolds goes up and takes a
hit away from lindor
on the ground amanda c
and brady singer has seven hitless
innings in cleveland
and the royals lead big tonight
and a line drive into center field and
the shields didn't read it nikki might
have hit a knuckle ball out there
because he did not take the proper route
but nikki's on with a two out single
and witt lines it into center field
nikki lopez will round and score
and the royals lead is eight nothing so
make it eight runs with two outs and
this is the third inning tonight where
the royals have scored a run after two
outs and nobody on base wow man to see
now we'll turn around and bat right
handed
and monday
blasted into deep left field
and that is gone
and the royals have scored four more
runs with two outs in the eighth inning
wow where did that come from
out of nowhere monday it looked like he
was he was just taking a practice swing
and that ball jumped
second homer of the year does he get his
rhythm back that he had in the prior
inning
naked win hits it high in the air to
left field
and alex is there for out number one
and a ground ball dozier will take care
of it and there are two down in the
eighth inning full count and he's had a
few of those today he had six full
counts
ground ball single in the right field
and the no hitter is broken up by austin
hedges
and that snaps an o for 12 for hedges
his first hit with the indians breaks up
a no-hitter when a guy goes that long
and gives up a hit for the first time
just to go out there and remind him he's
done a great job
foul tip and a strikeout
brady singer pitches eight shutout
innings in cleveland tonight allowing
only one hit
[Music]
wow
i remember
cleveland's always played him tough
monteci throws to first
and that's the game the royals beat the
indians
11-1 and brady singer on the mount and
boy he has a lifetime of memories
already on this mound in cleveland